stéphanie grammond michel suau jai alai
castonguay bonsoir
je vais changer lors je vais commencer
par les pende europe et creuse un petit
mot tour de table stephanie
parce qu'on en parle depuis toujours est
ce qu'il ya eu du progrès est ce qu'on a
fait du chemin et on est encore à peu
près au même point devant ce phénomène
là d'une professionnalisation à
l'extrême défiscaliser bureau d'avocats
qui font que des gens très riches qui
s'en sortent mieux ça comme ça mais
quand on voit des révélations comme
c'est le disons que pour le contribuable
moyer jeu comme vous et moi qui payons
nos impôts au grand complet ça donne
vraiment mal au coeur de voir que des
riches comme ça qui qui qui s'en tire en
allant dans les paradis fiscaux est ce
que ça a changé il ya quand même des
efforts qui sont faits on le sait le
ocde a mis en place qui est une des
annonces qui ont été faites de ces
derniers mois pour essayer de ne
s'attaquer aux multinationales et à la
concurrence fiscale que les pays se
livrer entre autres donc il va
normalement y avoir quelque chose qui va
ressembler un dépôt minimal de 15 % pour
les grandes entreprises mais ce qu'on
aimerait voir maintenant si des lois qui
s'appliquent aux os et aux riches donc
pas seulement aux entreprises et aux
individus
c'est un accès le dernier boulot qui
manque est aussi il faudrait créer une
application de tous parce que c'est beau
d'avoir des one foot in ensuite aller
chercher l'argent et ça c'est loin
d'être facile puisqu'on veut éviter
c'est d'avoir est le fils qui passent
comme un grand chat lui type qui ramasse
les gens qui ont peu de confort grand
chose à se reprocher comme on l'a vu
dans le passé mais qui liste les
poissons exotiques dans les paradis
fiscaux les gros poissons qui sont plus
difficiles à attraper alors une hélice
nager parce que c'est plus compliqué de
s'attaquer à dire des riches et
puissants mais qu'à des gens qui
sommes ici au québec voilà belle image
michel st
la solution doivent nécessairement tenir
par l'international parce que s'il reste
un seul paradis fiscal souvenez vous
lors que la base du batik a déjà jusqu'à
ac reste sain ils vont aller là alors il
ya il ya des mais une multiplication de
petites les îles de jersey le luxembourg
des fois c'est mal et c'est ça qu'il
faut faire mais ça ne se fera que si les
grandes puissances se mettent d'accord
pour fermer ce trafic là
on parle de bien belles choses l ocde et
ailleurs
marche pascal est que je posais la
question à notre professeur invité au
bout du compte c'est de l'argent - dans
des coffres des détails
oui absolument un pays c'est compliqué
parce que michel le disait qu'un état ou
que des états qui font faire faux bond à
la communauté internationale ben tout le
château de cartes s'effondre et on a
l'impression que chaque pays ont un peu
son propre paradis fiscal puis ça fait
bien leur affaire les britanniques ont
les
lignes on gagne aussi les américains au
delaware les français ont le luxe en
boucle tout le monde m'a dit c'est
toujours la faute de l'autre s'est
jamais son propre paradis fiscal qui le
problème il faut donc ça c'est très
complexe puis même les états où on
pourrait avoir un peu plus de vigueur
comme le canada on sent que c'est là on
attend les autres étaient dans le
dernier budget d'écriture fruits les
evènes très bonne mesure qui disait
qu'on qu'au canada on ne pourrait plus
enregistrer des compagnons numéro à
numéro 110 qui sont les véritables
propriétaires de l'entreprise faucon
plus savoir qui sont les propriétaires
des compagnies numéro des jeux de
pouvoir se cacher derrière ça ce serait
bien mais la mise en application est
prévue en 2025
on donne 4 1 aux entreprises pour
s'adapter
les entreprises regardent puisque dix
banques et on a encore le temps
faudrait qu'on pressent le pas un petit
peu puis on a l'impression que parfois
s'il dans tous les milliers les milliers
de noms qui sont sortis il faut quand
même souligner qui a pas de politiciens
canadiens ya pas d'élus canadien il ya
jacques villeneuve blanquette vous
donner plus de détails sur
villeneuve julie soir il ya il ya des
inconnues j'entendais halak notre
journal et qui a trahi la dessus des
inconnus par ailleurs il n'y a pas de
s'il avait fallu qu'à des non tiens des
tony blair canadiens 11 on aurait parlé
de ça sur un autre ton là mais bon je
referme la parenthèse
parlant de ton monsieur legault a dit
bapt est le mien n'était pas le ton
idéal la semaine dernière je vous fais
lire ce qu'il a écrit sur sa page
facebook avant la panne de facebook où
il dit je suis bien on va voir l'extrait
je suis bien conscient qu'à l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière on n'a pas
envoyé le message de compassion et de
solidarité que la situation exige de
nous comme premier ministre j'ai le
devoir de donner l'exemple donc un mea
culpa qui était ami chasser auger
nécessaire selon vous je suis pas
absolument nécessaire on a tous le droit
d'avoir une mauvaise semaine
mais des fois c'était lui qui était
l'instigateur de la bataille avait là
dessus c'est vrai que dans le tas qui se
battaient beaucoup au rock hill du dec
tel banc des punitions avec l'autre
c'est pas
moi j'étais très heureux de voir
monsieur legault faire cette mise au
point elle était nécessaire maintenant
il faut aussi c'est juste aux
discours des québécois toute son
histoire sur l'axé systémique ce système
ce qui va nécessiter mais que c'est
justement souvent des choses avant
l'euro perd une loi qu'il ya des fn ont
pris des choses comme ça
92 % des québécois dans les sondages de
cet ep disaient qu'ils croient que les
autochtones sont victimes de
discriminations le gâtisme
qui a peur de quoi peser au boulot ouais
mais allait qu'il serait parce que
demain d'ailleurs il y aura conférence
de presse de la coronaire ce serait
étonnant que monsieur leroux chargé du
là dessus quand même
changé d'idée il est allé trop loin dans
la rhétorique pour soudainement faire
volte-face par contre dans le ton ça ça
peut être adaptée c'est bien que promus
nice est reconnu que ça avait été une
semaine difficile sur ce plan là mais je
voudrais que depuis en quelques semaines
françois legault ont un ton qui
peut-être un peu inapproprié par rapport
au moment politique où on se trouve on
al'impression françois legault il va
être en campagne électorale dans deux
semaines puis un nom un niveau d'énergie
ou de vidéos au jt ou d'agressivité dit
le comme vous voulez qui semble pas tout
à fait en accord avec l'ambiance quand
c'est pas
c'est parce qu'on veut pas faire de
journée fériée parce qu'on manque de
productivité au québec des bressans
quand on attaque les partis d'opposition
assez rapidement même si aucune question
solennel comme la la réconciliation avec
les autochtones je sais pas qui est dit
à françois legault là il fallait
absolument qu'il soit en mode attaque
pendant toute l'année mélanie va être
longue c'est ce mode là alors qu'est-ce
que permis à françois le goût d'être
aussi populaire c'est justement le ton
un peu plus rassemblant empathique qu'il
a adoptées pendant la pandémie et lors
de l'impression qui la seule chose qui
souhaitent faire s'est polarisée
polariser sur tous les débats qui lui
pas souvenez depuis maintenant un mois
j'ai fait en accord avec ce que les gens
s'attendent à ce temps ci de l'année
politique ouais stéphane est un petit
mot là dessus
moi je suis d'accord
c'était extrêmement mal venu pour dire
le moins mais moi ce qui me ce qui
m'attriste quand je vois tout ça c'est
qu'on fait un débat autour du terme
racisme systémique
et puis peut-être que monsieur legault
pourrait ses peintures et dans l'eure
dans un coin puis s'attache aux
personnes le marché sur la peinture mais
au delà de ça c'est que on s'attaque pas
aux vrais enjeux
on a vu la semaine dernière que les
recommandations du rapport vié qui s
attaquer au problème entre les
autochtones et les services publics y à
peu près pas de choix qui a été fait sur
ses recommandations la une une formation
qui avaient été mises en oeuvre dans son
entier les services de santé suite à la
mort de joyce et chaque roanne et il ya
peu près seulement 1% les gens qui l'ont
choisie on sait que c'est la pandémie
peuhmond et occupé mais quand même et
quand on regarde du côté des services la
dpj il ya une solution qu'avait été a
mises de l'avant pour que les
autochtones puissent s'occuper davantage
de leurs de leurs enfants et québec pour
une question de deux juridictions me met
des bâtons dans les roues au volant tout
ça c'est des dossiers au delà de
vocabulaire pour n'utilise acquis et est
important et il ya toutes ces mesures le
concret auquel il faut s'attaquer
prorogation de la session
bon c'est un classique michel système
classique qui va vous parliez de temps
de renouveau ça aide aussi quand on
reprend il ya un grand discours on place
les objectifs donc ça peut peut-être
apaisé un peu les choses non oui mais ça
va rester une eau minérale celui-là
délectera l'accord s'il ya élection
banlieue de 3,9 en mai prochain ça
permet d'aller droit dans
une pâte
cela dit ça permet d'enlever le bois
mort savez quand on les projets de lois
demeurent plus au feuilleton comme
c'était le cas avant on peut les ramener
à l'étape où il était mais ce qu'on veut
pas réveiller encore des projets de loi
sur la réforme du mode de scrutin qui
sont instables d'assemblée nationale de
sympa se rapporte au long de ces alors
ça permet un bon français de ce focus et
sur ce qu'on veut faire de faire
vraiment le point sur ce qu'on peut
faire de la dernière année du mandat
adopté ce qui est important probablement
par exemple les amendements à la loi
certes il y avait un projet de loi dit
mahmoud que c'est lui même qui a employé
l'expression de faire passer est bon ça
c'est donc arriver avec un certain
nombre de choses à l'élection en même
temps toujours un danger ça passe
puis comme on disait au parlement le
somme si ça peut faire des grosses le
belge oui avec aussi le le contexte a
changé le la pandémie on commence à voir
un apaisement de code de ce côté là donc
il ya quelque chose de normal acheté
cette année de l'opposition aujourd'hui
vers la prorogation épouvantable comme
dell comme a dit michel les projets de
loi tombe pas la trappe non plus là non
j'étais un peu la vieille cassette des
partis d'opposition et qui disent que
c'est un exercice inutile ils vont pas
dire évidemment que je te veux que je te
suis tout à fait à propos mais ce l'est
en réalité seul et parce que depuis un
an et demi le gouvernement du québec est
occupé à gérer une pandémie françois
legault a un peu perdu là la carte
routière qui l'avait mise en place avant
la pandémie puis le sait bien qui nous
redisent bon il me reste peu de temps
pour me rendre jusqu'à la destination
voici ce que je vais prioriser parce que
c'est plus le temps de ces papiers là on
n'a plus le temps de remplir toutes les
promesses électorales et des choses
évidemment qui seront pas accompli mais
reste encore assez de deux mois et deux
semaines pour accomplir certains grands
enfants de ce qu'on avait prévu lesquels
temps quels domaines on va aller la
santé les services de garde visiblement
veut compléter le réseau des cpe donc il
nous précise sur quoi il va mettre son
énergie pendant la dizaine de mois avant
l'été puis après ça vient ça va être la
campagne électorale c'est tout à fait
normal qu'on essaie de mettre de
remettre les compteurs à zéro là à ce
moment ci demande je vous montre des
chiffres on a rarement vu ça où si l'on
tente qu'on ne j'aime gbagbo jamais mon
eau rare match un premier minesec un
taux de satisfaction aussi grave on va
voir des tableaux des filets voyez vous
satisfait
65% et satisfait 31 et ceux qui donnent
intentions de vote le prochain tableau
monsieur legault qui domaine vraiment
totalement le jeu politique québécois 47
pour cent d'appuis les libéraux à 20
québec solidaire on spécule 11 le parti
conservateur qu'il faut surveiller à 8
de monsieur duhaime donc tour de table
stephanie grand bon monsieur legault
tiac qui ont commencé fait la synthèse
du fédéral et celui des nationalistes
des souveraines et il récolte cette
synthèse là encore pas mal
c'est quand même phénoménal le laisse
les résultats des sondages
on aurait pu imaginer là à voir certains
certains une mule que françois legault
et le dernier rebond s'est prononcé en
faveur
des conservateurs aux dernières
élections ont finalement c'est justin
trudeau qui a été élue lit on en parlait
il ya quelques instants la de ratés qui
ont eu lieu puis du ton plus acrimonieux
au cours de la dernière semaine et même
un peu plus on a compris imaginer qu'il
y avait peut-être une petite baisse dans
les sondages vient d'abord du tout non
merci je suis désolé parce que je veux
comme celle et alec tetra 30 secondes
chacun alec y vole
oui absolument ça prend du temps avant
d'égratigner une carapace de la
l'épaisseur qui est celle que françois
legault s'est forgée pendant la pandémie
c'est pour les derniers événements qui
allaient faire beau perdre beaucoup de
plumes faudra voir la prochaine à l'ippj
partie des choses mais clairement
actuellement c'est encore et de loin le
premier ministre le plus populaire
depuis mon dieu tellement longtemps
rendu une dernière a dit demande est
tout aussi en avance dans les intentions
de vote on au pôle social on abat depuis
les mesures modernes je crois dire qu'on
a jamais mme chassé je pense que nos
professions effectivement il ya deux
raisons à cela d'abord sur le plan de
l'identité de ces choses là monsieur
lebon de nos québécois exactement ce
qu'ils veulent c'est à dire le pq se
référa dame l'a vécu la saveur bernard
landry le plus économique avec pas de
référendum à la clé sont très satisfaits
de sa d'autre part l'opposition est
morcelé en trouant et elle a pas trouvé
c'est de cheval de bataille n'a pas
encore trouvé de façon d'attaquer le
gouvernement ce lundi à leur décharge
pour facile de personnes
vers aussi une année sans pandémie va
changer la donne je suis merci beaucoup
à vous trois bonne fin de soirée à très
bientôt au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh